In today's lecture,
we're going to look at a
1985 Massachusetts case
called American Mechanical
Corporation Versus Union of Lynn.
Using that case,
we'll look at how to calculate contractual
damages available to a seller when
the buyer breaches,
and we'll also talk about the
seller's duty to mitigate damages.
In American mechanical.
The plaintiff American contracted to sell
its real estate for $100,000 and it's
business equipment for
$35,000 to the defendant.
Union Union knew that American was in
financial difficulty and that it was
behind on his mortgage payments to
Sagas bank and that Saugus was pressing
American to sell its assets.
Union issued a $5,000 down payment
to be held in escrow until closing.
A couple of weeks later,
union repudiated the contract.
Sagas Bank took possession of both the
property and business equipment from
American and sold them for
$55,000 and $35,000 respectively.
The highest prices it was able to
obtain American sued union for breach of
contract.
The trial court held for American
but awarded only nominal damages.
The instant court affirmed the judgment
in favor of American as the non
breaching seller but re
but reversed as to damages.
So this is the central issue
is the plaintiff entitled
to actual damages if the
damage is proved by the traditional
formula or insufficient.
The court held that it was an award
at American $45,000 plus interest.
The traditional rule for calculating
damages for breach of an agreement to sell
real estate is to award the difference
between the contract price and the market
price at the date of breach.
The trial court determine that the
$55,000 obtained for the property at four
foreclosure at the foreclosure sale
which took place seven months after the
breach was not a fair estimate of the
market value on the date of breach and
then American had failed
to prove actual damages.
Therefore the court awarded
only nominal damages. However,
the appeals court held that
the traditional formula is
not a rigid one and that
the aim and measuring damages in the
event of a breach is to place the injured
party in as good a position as he
would have been had the contract been
performed.
This is uh,
is of course the standard for expectation
damages according to the court and
important aspect of this principle is
that if a party suing for breach of
contract has sustained a loss as a result
of a breach and the loss is such a ne
is of such a nature that it was
reasonably foreseeable by the parties or
actually within their contemplation at
the time the contract was entered into,
then that loss may be recovered
in an action for damages.
Since Union knew that if the sale
of the property did not go through,
the result would be that Sagas bank would
enforce it's right under the mortgage
and that a foreclosure sale was likely
the correct measure of damages on
traditional contract principles was
the full amount of the actual loss,
the contract price,
less the amount received for the
property at the foreclosure sale.
Therefore American was entitled to
$45,000 the difference between a hundred
thousand dollars the contract price
and the 55,000 foreclosure sale price.
At what time is the market value of real
estate relevant under the traditional
rule for calculating damages,
suppose that American provided evidence
that the market value was $75,000 at the
date of the breach and $70,000
at the date set for closing.
What result under the court's reasoning?
Well,
under the traditional rule,
damages are equal to the difference
between the contract price and the market
price.
At the date of the breach,
that would be a hundred thousand
minus 75,000 or $25,000 in this case,
neither the trial court nor the appellate
court applied the traditional formula.
The traditional formula
requires an estimate of the
market value of the property
at the date of breach.
Since this was unavailable,
the trial court held that damages
could not be calculated and awarded and
awarded only nominal damages.
The Appellate Court,
however hell that even though American
didn't prove are required element of the
market value formula,
it did prove a foreseeable loss and that
including this loss in the damage award
more closely resonates with the
medical of expost compensation.
Such reasonably foreseeable losses are
known as consequential damages and we'll
talk more about them in a later lecture.
When we cover case called Hadley
vs Baxendale consequential
damages are usually
though only awarded to a buyer when a
seller is breach causes a foreseeable lost
to the buyer who is denied the
services flowing from the sailors.
Failure to perform the UCC section two
seven 15 expressly limits consequential
damages that as those that are
resulting from a seller's breach.
But American mechanical is a case where
a buyer's breach causes foreseeable
consequential damages.
And while the UCC does not expressly
provide for a seller's consequential
damages,
the uniform land transaction act
does provide for a seller's cons of
consequential damages that include quote
any loss the buyer knew or at the time
of contracting had reason to know would
result from the buyer's breach in which
reasonably could not be
avoided by the seller.
American mechanical also
touches on this last point,
the seller's duty to mitigate damages
in the event of a breach by the buyer.
The court noted that union would of course
be entitled to have Americans damages
reduced to the extent that American
could reasonably have avoided the loss.
In other words,
if once it knew of the breach,
American could reasonably have
sold the property to someone else,
it would be entitled to damages in an
amount no greater than the difference
between the contract price and the
price for which it could have sold the
property,
but the facts demonstrate that American
was unable to secure another purchaser
for the realty and the equipment.
The court also noted that the buyer
bore the burden to prove that the losses
could have been avoided
by reasonable effort.
Section three 50 of the restatement
describes the duty to mitigate.
It says that quote,
damages are not recoverable for loss,
that the injured party could have
avoided without undue risk burden or
humiliation,
but that the injured party is
not precluded from recovery
to the extent that he
has made reasonable but
unsuccessful efforts to avoid loss.
Let's look at the burden in American
mechanical and how it shifts.
First, the plaintiff has the
burden of proving damages,
but the defendant has the burden to
show that the plaintiff did not mitigate
damages.
Thus,
the court uses the mitigation rule to
shift the burden to prove the market value
of the property at the date of breach
from the plaintiff to the defendant at
trial.
The defendant might not have known that
it had this burden because the law was
not well enough established.
Arguably,
it would have been more appropriate for
the appellate court to remand for a new
trial to see if union could establish
Americans failure to mitigate damages.
Let's review today.
We talked about how to calculate contract
damages when a buyer breaches under
the traditional rule,
damages are calculated as the difference
between the contract price and the
market price at the time of the breach.
Damages may also include
consequential damages,
losses that are reasonably
foreseeable in the event of a breach,
although the seller has a duty
to mitigate those damages.